their Carriage will be horse drawn on
Saturday this one less Majestic but
there's a royal link as William and Kate
ride the line named after the late Queen
they took the tube to Soho as pubs and
people gear up for the coronation
good good thank you all goes well good
fingers crossed good weather as well
inside the bar the beers flowing so too
the coronation conversation the recent
rehearsals Kate says are helpful
it's gonna be good
at Westminster Abbey rehearsals are well
underway and inside they're setting up
for a spectacle on a huge scale
everything is on a really startling
scale I'm the dean of Westminster I'm
used to ceremony on a national level
even I think this is pretty jaw-dropping
one of the dean's responsibilities
handling Saint Edward's Crown easily the
centerpiece of Royal regalia but
historically hard to tell front from
back RC grit is not to type it's a
thread to it because someone removes
them but just to practice picking it up
and handing it to someone and having so
rehearsed the number of movements that
it is the right way around by the time
it gets to where it needs to be these
are the flowers which will fill the
Abbey picked from each of the four
nations and chosen to represent the king
and queen's love of gardening
the king I'm told has been relaxed in
rehearsals walking through this complex
ceremony step by step there is of course
a reason for all these run throughs he
knows his every move will be watched by
millions and millions
and not all of them as loyally as the
growing crowds already gathering for a
glimpse of the king as he heads to his
coronation Laura bundock Sky News